The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DAVID THORBURN: There
are various kinds
of neorealisms, flavors of
neorealism-- an Italian flavor,
a French flavor.
There is a kind of
tonal difference
that's worth paying
attention to.
And I maybe I can capture
it over-simply in two
short clips for you.
So the first clip
I want to show you
is from an Italian neorealist
film, the last really
powerful fully neorealist film
that De Sica himself directed,
a film called Umberto
D, made in 1952.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
DAVID THORBURN: And this
is our hero, of course.
-[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
-
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID THORBURN: And compare
this-- think about this scene
and then compare t-- to the
opening scene of The 400 Blows
and you'll feel a
difference in mood, I think.
Even the music is a part of it.
So he's in great despair
here, and we in the audience
know that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
-
DAVID THORBURN:
Random dialogue--
we don't even know
who said that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Did you see how Umberto
looked at the man who
sat down next to him?
I think the purpose
of that close look
was to make the audience look at
him too, pay attention to him,
even though he
never says a word.
It's possible that
these scenes might
make some members
of the audience
think that he's thinking
about jumping off a building.
All right, freeze it, James.
Back it up two seconds.
This is the last moment in the
scene that I want you to see.
Look what happened here.
Why are you smiling?
AUDIENCE: It's because
he was facing--
DAVID THORBURN: Speak
up so everyone can hear.
AUDIENCE: It's
because he was facing
towards the middle of the bus.
And then, Umberto, he got up--
[END PLAYBACK]
--and he turned right forward.
DAVID THORBURN: Yes, as
if he had more space.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DAVID THORBURN:
But then what else?
What about the gesture?
What do we feel about this man?
Never says a word.
Sits down next to him Umberto.
When he goes like this,
what do we feel about him?
He has some horrible story too.
He maybe is in much
despair as Umberto.
The point, of
course, is remember
I talked quite a bit
in earlier lectures
about what I called
the retarding
impulse in certain
neorealist films
and also in certain films of
Renoir-- the extent to which
what suddenly happens, as the
camera is looking at the world,
it finds a locus of
interest that may
be distracting in some sense.
Now it doesn't truly
distract in the sense
that it takes you off completely
on a digressive course.
But what it reminds you of is
the complexity of the world.
What it reminds you of--
this particular scene
especially-- is there's plenty
of despair to go around.
What it reminds you of is
that the story that has not
been told about this man--
this silent, suffering,
working man who sat down next
to old Umberto-- probably
has a story, just as
poignant, just as terrible
as Umberto himself.
And it's one of the
ways that the film
has of enlarging
the implications
of the individuated
story that it tells.
But the most significant
thing about this moment--
so it's a moment in which the
camera doesn't actually swerve,
but even though our hero, the
protagonist, moves off the bus,
the camera stays briefly
on that man with the hat.
Can we watch it-- just the very
end, James-- one more time,
just to get another look at it?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
See, that's a gesture
of, what, despair?
[END PLAYBACK]
Misery?
Sadness?
Sorrow?
Reflection over what terrible
things are about to happen?
And the idea that that
story has not been told
is as significant for our
understanding of the film
as the story that is told.
So there's a
similar-- I don't want
to call it a digressive
impulse, but let's call it
an impulse toward
noticing what is not
at the center of the story.
We might call it an impulse
toward a partial kind
of abstraction, an attentiveness
to the world that is always
threatened or challenged
by new options
that it might want to look at.
And not all of these impulses
lead to misery or despair,
even in the
neorealist tradition.
But the point I want
to make is that I
think the neorealist
tradition lays more emphasis
on social problems.
Its stories are often parables
of impoverishment or parables
about disempowerment.
Now the film you're going to
see tonight, The 400 Blows,
could in many ways be said
to fit that description.
But there's a lightness,
a lyricism in it,
that doesn't sustain the heavy
mood, the mood of disturbance,
the mood of-- if not tragedy--
of misery, or at least
of very alert social
awareness that
permeates neorealist films.
So here's a moment from the film
you're going to see tonight.
But it's a very
distracting moment.
You won't forget
it, when you see it.
And I'm doing a little harm
to your experience of the film
by calling your attention
to it, because it's
such a strange
moment in the film.
The hero is one of these two
boys, the boy on the left.
And the guy on the
right-- if you're
facing the film-- to your left
is the hero, the protagonist.
And the boy on the right
is his best friend.
The girl in the
middle is a sister.
And they're accompanying
this girl-- this
is in the middle of the film.
We're not even told where
they're going when it happens,
but they're going to the
park to watch a puppet show.
And watch what happens.
We're in the middle of the film.
We already know a
lot about the boys.
The boys have played
hooky, neither of them
get along very well
with their parents.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[YELLING]
-
DAVID THORBURN:
Freeze it second.
They're talking about stealing a
typewriter to get money, right.
So all right, continue.
-[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[YELLING]
-
[END PLAYBACK]
DAVID THORBURN: One
thing I should say
immediately is that it is that
this scene alone would give you
a very false sense of
the film, if this was
all you ever saw of the film.
And the fact is it comes
as a tremendous shock
when you're watching it.
Although you enjoy it
when you're watching it,
you're wondering,
why has Truffaut
spent so much time
on these faces,
so much time on these children?
We never go back
to such a scene.
None of the little
children's faces
that we see there do we
ever see again in the film.
Something happens
to the movie here.
It's almost as if
it gets sidetracked.
It's interested in the
boy and in his friend.
And when we're
watching this scene,
it certainly occurs to us
in the film, my goodness,
the scene might be useful, but
why has it gone on so long.
And I think the simple answer
is that Truffaut, the camera,
became preoccupied by
the astonishing variety
and vivid individuating
complexity of those children's
faces, that the
drama of that became
so interesting to the
camera, to the filmmaker,
that he couldn't quite
desert it without giving it
its just due, even
though from a narrative
standpoint it doesn't really
advance the story very well.
But that moment,
when we do cut back
to the two older boys
sitting in the back,
talking about
stealing something,
does justify this scene.
Why?
What does it show?
That they're separated
from innocence.
That they're too old for this.
They're sitting there,
everybody else in the audience
is absolutely rapt.
Now they're a little younger.
The implication is these
boys can't participate
in the joy of innocence any
longer, that they're already
too old for it in
some sense, and almost
because of their own behavior,
the choices they've made.
So the scene does further a
central element in the film,
clarifying our sense that
especially the protagonist
of the film is being wrenched
too quickly out of childhood,
is being forced out of
childlike circumstances
into circumstances
that no child should
have to should have to face.
So it does in some
sense dramatize that.
But it dramatizes that
in a very imperfect way
if that were its
primary purpose.
And what we have to say is, no,
that's not its only purpose.
The film is stopping
here and watching
this joy in these children
for the same reason
that Jean Renoir
stopped to watch
Boudu do his tricks
in the water--
not because it was
furthering any plot,
but because the spectacle
of Boudu's pleasure
became what was interesting
that the film, to the filmmaker,
and to the camera.
And so one way to understand the
difference between these forms
of new realism, these kinds
of neorealism-- the Italian
and the French-- is to
say that the French is
more open to this lyrical joy,
that there's a lighter tone,
that the social and political
dimensions of the story
are not obliterated in
Nouvelle Vague films.
But they play a lesser
role, they're less central.
There is no programmatic
social message
in most of the
Nouvelle Vague films,
even though there
is by implication--
as you'll see in The 400 Blows--
certainly a powerful critique
of adult society and the ways
in which disempowered creatures
like children are treated
in modern society.
And that theme is there,
it's at the center of it,
and there's no question
that it's significant.
But it is surrounded by
other complicating attitudes
and things that make the
version of new realism
that the French develop
in the decade beginning
around 1959 different in
tone from its origins.
Well, let me very quickly say
a little bit about the origins
of the Nouvelle Vague.
You're prepared for this.
And if I showed you this
film without any background,
and I said, where
does this come from,
my hope is that most
of you would say,
oh, I can see Italian
neorealist elements here,
I can see Renoirish
elements here.
A really acute and
perceptive student
might even see that this
line goes back to Chaplin.
And Chaplin's
films are committed
to forms of realistic
representation
that is in a line, I think,
with these later, more complex
films, more visually
complex films.
And in fact, there's an allusion
to Chaplin in tonight's film.
I hope you'll watch for it.
One of the teachers actually
plays a Chaplin-like role
at a certain point.
And there's no
question that the film
intends to invoke the joy
and pleasure of the Chaplin
character in the
memory of its audience
when those allusions occur.
So the origins of the Nouvelle
Vague-- first in Jean Vigo
and in French poetic realism,
in the practices that
are developed by John Renoir
and other directors of the time,
that kind of lyrical,
improvisatory open camera
of Renoir, and then
the way in which those
are adapted by the
Italians, very much
influenced by the French.
So those traditions are at the
center of the Nouvelle Vague.
And the primary practitioners
of the Nouvelle Vague,
directors like Truffaut
and Jean-Luc Godard,
and Alain Resnais,
and Jacques Rivette,
and a number of other
directors-- Louis Malle,
a little older, one who
would make magnificent films.
It's a wonderful, wonderful
group of really significant
directors.
Most of them still alive, but
in their dotage now-- even older
than I am, if you
can believe that--
and with magnificent
careers behind them,
all starting in this moment of
the late '50s when French film
took a new energy from
the critical discourses
of the critics who were working
for Cahiers du Cinema, which
I'll talk about in a second.
So one central source
for the Nouvelle Vague
are these earlier
film traditions.
And the directors who made
the Nouvelle Vague were quite
self-conscious about
this-- many of them
had spent a decade before
they became directors writing
for Cahiers du Cinema,
the great magazine founded
in 1951 by Andre Bazin,
the critic I've talked
about earlier in the course.
And probably Truffaut
was the most well-known
of the critics who
worked for the magazine.
Truffaut spent at least
seven or eight years
working for Cahiers du Cinema
before he made his first film.
And in their time working
for Cahiers du Cinema,
they actually articulated
certain theories
of movie making.
One of the theories
that they articulated,
or an aspect of their
overriding theory,
was articulated in an article--
a very famous article-- written
by Truffaut himself before he
became a director, before he
became an actual director.
And the title translated went
something like this-- A Certain
Tendency of French Cinema.
He published this essay in
Cahiers du Cinema in 1954.
And it was an attack
on what he called
the tradition of quality,
in quotes the "tradition
of quality" in French movies.
It attacked contemporary
French movies for being stiff,
for being too literary,
for being too much
of the establishment.
And the other
thing that article,
and many other articles in
Cahiers du Cinema did, was they
began to write very favorably
about American studio
directors, the directors who
worked under the Hollywood
system most effectively, among
them especially Hitchcock.
And in fact Truffaut did
a series of interviews
with Hitchcock later
published as a book, Truffaut
on Hitchcock, or
Truffaut/Hitchcock.
I forgot the exact
title in English.
It has a different
title in French.
It's a very interesting
series of interviews.
And those of you who
are interested in this
might want to look at it.
Because one of the
comical things that
happens in the interviews
is you constantly see
Truffaut, who's much more
articulate and theoretically
subtle than Hitchcock
is-- abstractly,
I don't mean Hitchcock's
not a great theorist,
but he's a practicing
theorist-- and you constantly
see Truffaut trying
to turn Hitchcock
into an intellectual and
Hitchcock refusing, Hitchcock
saying, no, no.
It's almost as if
Truffaut is disappointed
that Hitchcock can't articulate
the theories that Truffaut
wants him to articulate.
So Truffaut is constantly
trying to make Hitchcock
into a great director,
and Hitchcock
is often in the interview
saying, I make genre movies,
leave me alone, I just
want to entertain people.
So it's comical.
And in fact I do think that
the French inflated-- Truffaut
especially-- inflated
Hitchcock's reputation, maybe
even beyond what it
actually deserved.
But in any case, it was
subversive of the Cahiers du
Cinema critics to write about
American directors, studio
directors-- because
the American studios
were held to be the essence of
commercial popular art, nothing
artistic in it at all.
And in fact it was
these French critics
who first began to write
about American directors
in a way that showed respect,
recognized their complexity.
It's a great irony that
the French recognized
the artistic value
of American movies
before the Americans did.
And at the very time that
the Americans were swooning
over European art cinema,
this is the period
when the Nouvelle
Vague appears, when
I was in college-- in the
late '50s and early '60s.
And it was an extraordinarily
exciting time in the United
States for people
interested in movies,
not because of the American
movies that were being made,
but because there was
this astonishing-- what
seemed like an astonishing--
flower of European
and Asian cinema.
It's also the
moment of Kurasawa,
as I'll mention next week
when we talk about Rashomon,
and Kurosawa's intervention in
world cinema occurring earlier
in the 1950s, at the same time
as the Italian neorealists.
So it was an incredibly
exciting time.
And educated Americans
for the first time
began to realize that
the movies weren't just
popular entertainment, but
were serious works of art.
The irony is they recognized
this about European films
but not about their own films.
And it took another
generation really
before a serious attention
to American movies
was paid by American scholars
and American critics.
Interesting irony.
A further articulation
of some of
the theoretical underpinnings
of the Nouvelle Vague
came from the
director and theorist
Alexandre Astruc, born in 1923.
He was good director,
admired director.
But he's most well-known
as a critic, a theorist.
And his central theory,
then elaborated and embraced
by generations later
including Bazin
and the writers for
Cahiers du Cinema,
was focused on the
term camera-stylo,
camera-style, camera hyphen
pen, as if what he imagined
was that the camera
should be wielded
by the director with
the same subtlety
as the writer wields his pen.
And It was an idea that
the visual style of a film
could have the
suggestiveness and subtlety
of a literary work.
And when Astruc
articulated this,
it was rather a
revolutionary idea.
And it was elaborated,
further picked up.
And the directors
of Cahiers du Cinema
were very powerfully
in favor of what
came to be called the auteur
theory-- author, that's
French for author.
And the auteur
theory essentially
is that the director
of the film is
an author who
leaves his signature
in every frame of the film.
It's a radical
over-simplification of course,
because films are such
collaborative enterprises.
But it is still nonetheless true
that it grants to the director
a kind of respected
authority that is certainly
justified in the case
of many, many films,
where the director is
the dominant and central
creative energy.
And this of course has been
especially true in Europe,
and even more especially
true in France,
perhaps, than in
any other society.
So auteur was a very important
underpinning, encouragement
to the Nouvelle Vague.
So when these
critics-turned-movie makers
began to make movies,
they had already
made theory for why they were
doing what they were doing.
They were hostile to certain
forms of pretentiousness
in contemporary
French films, they
wanted some of the
energy and power
to entertain that they
associated with the most
gifted American
directors, but they also
wanted films that expressed
a signature individuality.
They thought films
ought to be and were
the expression of the
sensibility of their director.
And the film you're going
to see tonight certainly
embodies those values.
One way to think about the
moment at which the Nouvelle
Vague emerges in both
French and in global culture
is to think of the year
1955-60-- I used to say just
'59, but there's some dispute
about when Jean-Luc Godard's
film actually first
appeared, whether it was
'59 or '60, so I've added 1960.
But these three films appeared
within a very short time
of each other in 1959-60.
And all three of
them are thought
to be sort of the origins of the
Nouvelle Vague, the moment when
the Nouvelle Vague declared
itself as a major film
movement.
But Hiroshima, Mon Amour was
a dramatically important film
when it first appeared.
In the foreground of the
film is a story of a love
affair between a Japanese
architect and a French woman.
And the love affair
is in the foreground.
But in the background is
Hiroshima and the dropping
of the bomb on Hiroshima.
And the story of the lovers--
I don't mean that it takes
place while Hiroshima
is going on.
Hiroshima is
remembered and invoked
in the course of the film.
So the foreground of
the film are the lovers.
The background of the film
is this horrific event,
the atomic bombing of Hiroshima.
And the film plays
with our sense of time.
Its sense of the passage of
time is confused in some sense.
It's not linear in
the traditional sense
of an ordinary well-made film.
And there's not exactly
a surreal quality in it,
but there's a
quality in it that we
might say that one of
the things that happens
is that time is sometimes
treated subjectively
rather than objectively
in the film.
And so the time frames you're
in are often mixed or unclear
in the film.
The film was also much more
explicit with its nudity
than American
audiences were used to,
and it caused quite
a scandal when
it came to the United States.
I remember the people who were
in college with me at the time
were very excited to see
it, partly for that reason.
Nudity was much rarer
in the popular culture
when I was your age
than it is today.
An even more dramatic
and radical movie
was Jean-Luc
Godard's Breathless,
which tells the story of a
third-rate criminal played
with astonishing
panache by Jean-Paul
Belmondo with a cigarette
stuck in his lips
through most of the film.
And there's one moment in the
film where Belmondo walks up
to a movie marquee, I think,
outside a movie theater.
And he sees a poster advertising
a film with Humphrey Bogart.
And he looks at the
film and he tries
to imitate a Bogart move-- he
goes like goes, puts his arm,
Bogart had a move like this.
And he says something
like this, Bogie
he says in his French accent.
And you can see in a certain
way that he's patterning himself
on Bogart, the Bogart who played
ambiguous, sometimes criminal,
characters in the movies.
And it's one of the earliest
examples of something
that becomes really
common in America,
for example in the
great television series
The Sopranos, where all the
gangsters are constantly
invoking The Godfather and
other fictional gangsters,
and modeling themselves on them,
or quoting scenes from them.
Well, Belmondo's
character in Breathless
is one of the first gangsters
to pattern himself on gangsters
out of popular culture, instead
of being a real gangster.
And there's a moral ambiguity
in the film that is never
fully resolved, because
the protagonist of the film
is this-- we're not going to
show that, James, we don't have
time for it.
I was going to show you a
clip, but there's no time.
It's quite a remarkable film.
Some of you might
want to look at it--
it's available from
the film office.
And the central ambiguity
is that we identify
in some degree with the
protagonist-- we follow him
all the way through the film.
Very early in the
film he actually
commits a murder-- it's an
accident, he doesn't intend it,
it just sort of happens.
But he still is a murderer.
He steals a car in the
very opening scene.
And then he ends up
murdering someone.
He's on the run-- and
for the rest of the film,
he's on the run.
He takes up with
an American girl
played by Jean Seberg who ends
up betraying him to the cops.
And in the very final
scene in the film,
he's shot down by the police.
And we see him
running down a street
with a wound in
his back, finally
falling in a very dramatic
way with his girlfriend
coming and looking over him.
And the ending of the
ending of the film
is very strange,
because it leaves
the audience uncertain about
what its attitudes toward what
has happened ought to be.
Should we resent this betraying
girlfriend as an evil character
because she's sold her
boyfriend out to the cop?
On the other hand, her boyfriend
is an amoral murderer and thief
who doesn't seem to care
about anyone, much less her.
And yet there's a kind of
charm and an erotic energy
about the Belmondo character.
So the film's moral and
psychological grounding
is unclear.
And so it was very powerful and
significant for that reason.
And then finally The 400 Blows,
even more successful film
in a popular sense than
either of those two,
appears in the same time frame.
And it won the best director's
prize at the Cannes Film
Festival in 1960.
And it put Truffaut on the map.
It made Truffaut
a famous director.
And he never really
looked back after that.
He went on to have quite
a remarkable career.
Let me say a couple of
things about the style
and tone of the Nouvelle Vague.
Most of it applies to what we've
already said about neorealism
and about French poetic realism.
So there's no reason to
go through a lot of it.
But let's jump to the
bottom, to the items
at the end of the list.
First, the improvisatory
aspect of, let's say,
Renoir's practice
becomes even more pointed
and central in many of
the Nouvelle Vague films.
And there really is a
sense in which they often
would begin filming without
having a full script, letting
the story itself play
out, discover itself
as they were filming.
Tremendous amount
of collaboration
between performer and director.
So both plot and
dialogue are often
the result of a kind of
inspired improvisation.
Even more significant is the
commitment in the Nouvelle
Vague-- even more powerful,
much more powerfully
then than in the earlier
realisms-- toward use
of a style we might call
a discontinuous style,
a jumpy style, an edgy style.
What's a jump cut?
A jump cut is an
edit that takes place
in the middle of an action.
A normal cut, or what we
might call a classic cut.
If a character is
speaking and making
a gesture-- say the camera's
on me-- and he says,
I insist on this
idea more powerfully
than any other--
like this, right.
Well in a classic
sense, you would
wait until my fist came
down before you cut.
But if you did a jump cut,
it would say something
like, I insist on this
idea more than any other.
Or maybe not even let me
get the word "other" out
and it would cut
to another scene.
It creates a sense of
discontinuity or of jaggedness
that reminds you that life
itself is not so smooth.
And the other thing that
the jump cut reminds you of
is something else--
it reminds you
of the presence of the editor.
It reminds you that you
are watching a film.
It's a very quiet
way of doing this,
And these films have other, more
explicit, ways of reminding you
that you're watching a film.
But there is in
these films not only
the use of discontinuous
editing and what
David Cook in his A
History of Narrative Film
calls elliptical
editing, in which things
are much more compressed,
much more elliptical.
Things are not always
perfectly worked out.
Remember I've talked
about this earlier, how
in classical Hollywood style if
I were walking toward the door
they would show me walking.
When I got here,
they might cut it,
and then they might pick up the
scene as I reached the door.
But in a Nouvelle
Vague film, they
might show me going
like this, and the next
cut I'd be in the next room
or in bed with my girlfriend.
They wouldn't bother
to show-- in my case,
it would be my wife,
please, important.
But they wouldn't bother
to show that progress,
because it's silly,
it's unnecessary.
That's what is meant
by elliptical editing.
And it makes a greater
demand on the audience.
But it also has the
effect of creating
a continuous, quiet sense of
what I call self-reflexiveness
or self-awareness in the film.
That is to say, you are
aware at almost every moment
of these Nouvelle
Vague films that it
is an artifact, that the film
has been made by human hands,
that various strategies
and gestures have
created these effects.
And that distances you from
the material in some sense.
But it opens out a new topic.
And that new topic
is film itself.
And many of the
Nouvelle Vague films--
and especially the films that
come after the Nouvelle Vague,
but influenced by it--
turn out to be films
that one of their topics is the
making of movies themselves,
films about film.
And there are a couple of
wonderful examples of this
in Truffaut's own corpus
of work, including
a very lovely, gentle film
called-- a light film, not
as profound as his
most powerful films,
but a beautiful, beautiful
film-- the French title
is La Nuit Americaine.
But it was translated in the
English-speaking world as Day
for Night.
If you want to
create the illusion
that you're filming
at night, you
can put a filter on the camera.
And even though you're
filming during the day,
it will look nighty,
it will look dark.
It's a strategy of
directors of photography.
And it's an allusion to that.
It's called The American
Night because this
was a strategy that was
especially associated
with American movies, thought
by the French-- especially
by the Nouvelle
Vague directors--
to be shocking and
ridiculous, because you should
film on location.
You should minimize
the falsity that
is involved in setting up
filters for your film-- faking
that it's night when
it's really not,
or faking that it's day when
it's right, that kind of thing.
But the film, La Nuit Americaine
Is about the making of a film.
And in it Truffaut
himself I think appears.
He plays the director who is
having trouble making a film.
And is the film is
interesting about character.
It studies the
psychological circumstances
of its central characters with
great subtlety and interest.
It says powerful and
interesting things
about the erotic and
personal connections
among serious adults.
And it also says something
about what is involved
in the making of a film.
It's about making movies.
Its subject matter is
the making of a film.
That level of self-reflexiveness
or self-consciousness
is always present in at least
some degree in these films.
And sometimes it can become
an explicit central topic.
These films, as I've
already indicated,
are full of allusions and
references to earlier films.
And I mentioned the
references to Chaplin--
you'll see other references
like this, I think, in the film.
And one thing that happens
in this film, for example,
is that the characters
go to the movies.
There's a moment when the
family goes to the movies.
And the film that's
playing is the title
of a film by a friend of
Truffaut's, Jacques Rivette,
a film called Paris
Belongs to Us.
And it's a real film.
So it's a kind of allusion
in a way, to another film,
to a friend.
But again, there's a level
of self-reflexiveness
in which that
sequence in the film
is also a meditation on the
role of movies in social life.
I'll come back to
that in a second
when I talk a little bit
about The 400 Blows itself.
So let me say a word
about Francois Truffaut.
I hope you'll read
more deeply about him
in Wikipedia and
in other places.
His biography is very
rich and interesting.
One decisive thing to say
about it is that in some sense
The 400 Blows is a deeply
autobiographical film.
That is to say, Truffaut
himself was born out-of-wedlock,
lived with his grandmother.
Not all the details are
exactly the same in the film,
but these details I'm
giving you will show you
how closely the film mirrors the
reality of Truffaut's own life.
He was raised by his grandmother
until he was eight years old.
Then he lived with his
mother and his stepfather,
who gave him his name.
And you'll see that that's
an issue in this film too.
The father of Antoine Doinel,
the central character,
is his stepfather,
not his real father.
Lived with his mother and his
stepfather until he was 14.
Was constantly
truant from school.
His father ended
up turning him in,
and he spent time
in a reformatory.
To escape his parents
and other miseries,
he joined the army at the age
of 18, but he hated the army.
He was constantly looking
for a chance to desert.
He finally did desert the
army, and he was arrested.
He spent time in
prison for desertion.
And he was really
in big trouble.
But he had always loved
film, even as a kid.
And as a 14-year-old in
Paris, he had found his way.
You'll see that this is
replicated in The 400 Blows,
because the attraction
of Parisian movies
is one of the great escapes
for this boy and his friend.
So in his real life
he loved movies,
and he went to the French
bibliotheque to watch films.
And there he met Andre
Bazin, who was already
an eminent critic and
was the co-founder
of Cahiers du Cinema.
Bazin intervened in his case,
apparently used his influence
to get him either released from
prisoner or have his sentence
reduced-- I don't know
the exact details.
He went to work for
Cahiers du Cinema.
And the rest is history.
He worked for something
like eight years
as a critic for
Cahiers du Cinema
and then began to
make his own films.
And one of the most
significant things
about his life as
a critic is that he
was famous for being
a nasty, incredibly
unsympathetic critic.
He was famous for the
viciousness and unforgiving
quality of his reviews.
And think what it means that
such a person should then,
after eight years of doing
this and making enemies
all over the French
film world, should
take the risk of beginning
to make a film on his own.
In many ways very bold of him.
But it's also true that
the Cahiers du Cinema
crew, as we might call it,
including the great eminence
of Bazin himself
and a whole bunch
of other ambitious young
critics would-be directors,
they constituted a kind
of critical mass of folks
with shared ambitions.
So I don't want
to make it appear
that what Truffaut was
doing was shockingly brave,
or courageous, or
self-destructive.
But it was a dangerous thing,
because he was certainly
opening himself to revenge
reviews by other people.
And he was really infamous for
being nasty to other directors,
especially to French directors.
You'll see on the outline
that I've listed some
of his most significant films.
And the films that
have asterisks next
to them, those five films, are
all about the same character
that you're going to
see in tonight's film.
They're all about
Antoine Doinel.
And it's a unique film record.
It's a series of
autobiographical films, played
by the same actor, who is a
kind of Truffaut stand-in.
And the second film that I
have on the list, or rather
the third film,
Antoine and Colette,
I have it in quotations because
it's not a feature-length film.
It's an episode from
an anthology film
that appeared in 1962
called Love at Twenty.
It was a very flattering
thing for the young director
to be asked to
contribute to that.
And so that's
another installment
of the story of Antoine Doinel.
And then the next
one takes place
in 1968, Stolen Kisses, again
in 1970-- Bread and Board.
And then finally, nine years
later, the final Doinel film,
Love on the Run.
It ends in an ambiguous
way, like all of the films.
And one of the wonderful things,
Jean-Pierre Leaud-- L-E-A-U-D,
I don't know how to
say it, Leaud, Leaud--
who plays Doinel, you can see
him aging through these films.
It's a wonderful sequence.
And if you like
The 400 Blows, you
might want to watch
the other films.
The 400 Blows is probably
the best of all of them,
but they're beautiful films.
And what they show
is, in some sense,
Truffaut returning to this
autobiographical theme
at different stages in his life.
There are even some scholars
who have suggested that there's
a kind of analogy, or
a mirror relationship,
between the young
Jean-Pierre Leaud,
the 14-year-old who plays the
central character in The 400
Blows, that there's an analogy
between his relationship
to Truffaut and Truffaut's
relationship to Bazin,
as if what's happened
is that Truffaut
with his new young actor
is re-enacting-- but now
on the other side-- the
mentor-mentee relationship
that Bazin and Truffaut
apparently enjoyed as well.
I don't have time to talk about
this remarkable list of films.
The only film on this
list that isn't wonderful,
I think-- certainly
worth looking at closely,
maybe two that are not
absolutely first-rate--
is the one in 1966,
Fahrenheit 451.
I mention it to you because it's
such an interesting example.
Based on the Ray Bradbury.
And it is his worst film.
It's his first
film in English, he
didn't know English very
well when he made it.
It's an oddly heavy-handed
and wooden film.
But I still have some
kind of affection for it,
even though it's not a
very good adaptation.
Because he was attentive
to Ray Bradbury,
attentive to the ambitions.
It's a film that's theoretically
much more interesting than it
is in practice.
But all the other films
are very remarkable films
and among the most significant
films of their day.
And let me just say one final
word about the last film I've
listed there, The Last Metro,
which starred Catherine
Deneuve and Gerard Depardieu.
In a way it's a
World War II film.
It tells the story of
a Jewish director who
has to hide in the hidden
basement of his theater
while his wife,
who is not Jewish,
is able to run the
theater above ground.
And it tells the story of
the importance of theater
even during the war
years, when Paris
was occupied by the Germans.
It's a very powerful and
moving love story, as well as
a story that celebrates
the power of theater
and the power of
art in hard times.
And it's a lovely,
poignant, powerful film.
I want to say a few words
about the film itself.
It's fairly
straightforward, and I think
you'll absolutely enjoy it.
First the title, weird
title, The 400 Blows.
It comes from a French idiom.
And the idiom means
something like
to sow your wild
oats, to raise hell.
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
To do or to make
the 400 blows means
essentially to raise hell,
to do a walkabout, something
that young people do.
And of course the
title is very resonant.
You end without any
certainty about what
the resolution of this wild
behavior is going to be.
The second important thing
to say about the film,
something I've implied
earlier, is that it's
a film that loves Paris.
And in a certain sense the
boy's odyssey through the film
is an exploration of Paris
and of Parisian delights.
And again, think of what it
says about the city, about
this great city, in the
time that the film was made,
that boys of this age could
wander around so safely
and engage in so many remarkable
adventures in the course
of an ordinary day in Paris.
So the film is attentive
to the feel, the texture,
of Paris, in
something of the way
that some of the
Italian neorealist films
were attentive to the
physical texture of Rome,
or of other Italian
environments.
The family romance at
the heart of this film
is one of Truffaut's
subtlest achievements.
And I just want to
call your attention
to how subtle it actually is.
Watch how the story
unfolds, and how
in a very brief
and elliptical way
we come to understand
the motivations
and the unhappinesses of each
of the major characters--
the mother, the
father, and the son.
What we discover fairly early
is that the mother isn't
that happy with her husband.
She feels that she's
losing her beauty,
she feels trapped in
an unhappy marriage.
The husband is to her a
kind of boring character.
He's the boy's stepfather.
Early in the film, we
get a wonderful sequence.
Remember, watch for the
principle of multiplicity
there, because so many things
are going on simultaneously.
The physical, and social,
and economic environment
within which the family
lives is dramatized
in those opening scenes.
The boy's relation to
his family is dramatized
in those opening scenes.
And the father's
relation to the mother
is dramatized in those
opening scenes as well.
And what we discover,
of course, is
that the father is
actually-- even though he's
the stepfather-- actually feels
great affection for the boy.
And they get along
very well, much better
than the boy gets along
with his mother, who
is actually his blood relative.
And the mother's resentment
partly has to do with the fact
that she must feel that
the boy has trapped her.
And she's entering
middle age, she
thinks she's losing
her beauty, she
thinks she's chained to a
child and to a marriage.
And you can feel this.
And there are certain
moments in the film when
the mother, for various reasons,
is embarrassed over the fact
that she seems to have
been a bad mother.
And she uses various strategies
to reach out to her son.
And some of them are kind of
creepy, as you'll discover.
She's a very complex character,
and the least sympathetic
character in the
film, because she
behaves in many ways so
shockingly toward her son.
But even she, the least
sympathetic character
in the film, is treated in the
film with a kind of complexity
that we expect from adults.
In other words, we
don't think that she's
an evil villainess
who would like
to suck the blood of her child.
Not at all, not at all.
What you feel is
that she's driven
to her hostilities
and her unhappinesses
by the confined and unhappy
circumstances of her life.
Not that she's totally
forgiven, but she's
understood by the film.
Something of the
same kind of thing
is true for the husband,
who loves his wife
and knows that his wife is
probably dissatisfied with him,
may be unfaithful to him.
And that colors his
relation to his son,
with whom he often feels
a great connection.
So there's a great
poignant sense
that this dysfunctional
family is less happy
than it needs to
be, if only it could
understand its circumstances.
There's one wonderful moment
in the film where some
of the hostility disappears.
And it comes at a moment
that I mentioned earlier
where the husband and the
wife go off to the movies
together, taking
their son with them.
It's like a family outing.
That's when they go to see
the Jacques Rivette film.
And it's the one moment
in the film where
all three of the central
characters in the film
are happy together.
And you might ask, why?
Well, the father is
happy because the wife
is paying attention to
him and is doing something
with the family.
And the boy is happy because the
family, the father and mother,
aren't squabbling
with each other
and they're including him.
And the mother is at
least partly happy
because she can
see both of the men
are delighted by what's going
on and because she likes movies
too.
So one of the things that
the film dramatizes is
the importance of
film in human life,
is how film is a kind of
escape or a respite from misery
in certain ways.
And so it's a kind of
commentary on the centrality
of the movies as a source
of information, insight,
and consolation.
Pay attention to the way
the film is structured.
It's not unlike what I've
said about the organic form
of certain earlier
Italian and French movies.
The structure unfolds
in a natural way.
We don't feel that plot
is driving the story,
we feel that what
happens in the film
happens out of a kind of
natural unfolding that
is a function of both the
environment and the characters.
There's so much that
I've left out here
that I feel guilty about
not having mentioned.
I should mention one
parenthetic remark,
just because it's
such a vivid detail.
The film was made for a
relatively small amount
of money, even in those days.
It cost $75,000 to
make this movie.
And in the United
States alone it
earned over $500,000, a gigantic
amount of money in those days.
So it was an astonishing
success in that way.
Let me end by saying
one final word
about the astonishing
conclusion of the movie.
The ending is beautiful
in its own right.
I mean there's a
kind of visual beauty
that's constantly competing for
your attention as you watch.
The boy, as you'll
see in the story,
ends up in a kind
of reform school.
His crimes are so
modest and that's
part of what makes
the film so poignant.
He's actually caught stealing--
not stealing-- the typewriter
that he was talking about
stealing in that scene you saw.
He's caught when he's trying
to return the typewriter.
He has an attack of
conscience, and he
thinks I shouldn't do this.
And he's caught
returning the typewriter,
and that's his big crime.
And you'll see, one of the
things that happens to him when
he's kicked out-- he runs
away from his family at one
point-- he spends
nights in Paris
on his own, this
14-year-old child, boy.
Very interesting
again, about the way
the film celebrates
the city of Paris
as a nurturing, adventurous,
exciting, not really dangerous
place.
But let me say one final
word about the ending.
At the end very end of the
movie, he kind of escapes.
He makes a kind of escape
from this reform school
that he's in.
And it's an immensely
beautiful sequence,
in which we see him running
through a countryside.
And it's a tracking shot, an
immense long tracking shot.
And the camera follows him
as he's running-- running,
running, running.
And it goes on, in some sense,
something like the scene
that I showed you, where
the puppet show seems
to be going on forever.
When you're watching
the film, you'll
see that it's strange, because
the puppet show intervenes
in the movie without explanation
and disappears from the movie
without explanation.
Something of the
same kind of thing
is true here, where the
beauty of the countryside
starts to compete
for your attention.
But in any case, finally
at the end of his run
he comes he comes to
a verge, to an end.
He comes to the water,
he comes to the sea.
He always said he
wanted to see the sea,
but this is a very disappointing
version of the sea.
And he runs up against it.
Watch how the music works.
There's a beautiful use
of a stringed instrumen--
I'm not sure what
instrument, maybe a guitar.
But anyway, a beautiful
stringed instrument
plays a melody that you've
heard earlier in the film.
And we see him running
up to this verge.
And then there's an
astonishing moment
in which he comes to a stop.
And he's looking at the water.
And the camera freezes on him.
There's a freeze
frame at the very end.
It's the most famous freeze
frame in the history of movies.
And after this film, the freeze
frame became a cheapo trick.
You began to find it in
television commercials.
But at the time that he
used this frieze frame,
it was an immensely
dramatic effect.
I don't mean nobody had ever
used such strategies before.
But it is one of the
subtlest uses of a freeze
frame in the history of movies.
And one of the reasons I
want you to watch for it
and pay attention to it,
is listen to the music
as it's going on.
Because the tune is finally
unfinished at the end.
In other words, where one
final note that isn't played.
But you've heard
the note before,
so you keep expecting it.
And that's part of the power of
that freeze frame at the end.
I think he's looking at us
when the freeze frame occurred.
But the point is, where is
he going, what comes next?
The film doesn't
really have an answer.
We don't know where
the film is going.
We don't know what's going
to happen to this boy.
So it ends on a note of
open-endedness and ambiguity
that's powerful and profound.
But what we also know
is that this has not
been an apocalyptic ending.
It's not a catastrophic ending.
The boy is isolated,
the boy is alone,
he doesn't know what's
going to happen to him,
he doesn't know whether
he'll be recaptured,
he doesn't know where
he's going to go.
But I don't think we have any
sense that he's going to die.
We don't have any sense that
this is the end of his life.
We have a sense,
maybe, that this
is the beginning of his life.
So that there's a
profound uncertainty,
a kind of beautiful uncertainty,
a beautiful ambiguity
at the end of the
movie, that is partly
captured in the complex
relation between sound and image
at the end of this movie.
Those of you who have
never seen The 400 Blows
are in for a really great treat.
The final films in this course
are among the greatest films
ever made.
I hope you enjoy it
as much as I did.
I still remember
the place in which
I saw this film and the
exhilaration I felt when
I came out of watching it, with
the recognition that movies
could be what great
novels had been.